when I spoke at this forum two years ago
I told you that we had launched the
great American comeback today I'm proud
to declare that the United States is in
the midst of an economic boom the likes
of which the world has never seen before
we've regained our stride we discovered
our spirit and reawakened the powerful
machinery of American enterprise
America's thriving America's flourishing
and yes America is winning again like
never before just last week alone the
United States concluded two
extraordinary trade deals the agreement
with China and the United States Mexico
Canada agreement the two biggest trade
deals ever made they just happen to get
done in the same week these agreements
represent a new model of trade for the
21st century agreements that are fair
reciprocal and that prioritize the needs
of workers and families America's
economic turnaround has been nothing
short of spectacular when I took office
three years ago America's economy was in
a rather dismal state under the previous
administration nearly 200,000
manufacturing jobs had vanished wages
were flat or falling almost 5 million
more Americans had left the labor force
than had gotten jobs and more than 10
million people had been added to the
Food Stamp rolls we've been so
successful that the United States no
longer needs to import energy from
hostile nations with an abundance of
American natural gas now available our
European allies no longer have to be
vulnerable to unfriendly energy
suppliers either we urge our friends in
Europe to use America's vast supply and
achieve true energy security